[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Diana
joins us in Los angelist Diana welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hello hi hey what's going on I have
I have a question so I have co-signed a
car with my mom she's 83 years old and
if she passes is the car going to be
mine well is the title in your
name yes okay and hers as well as the
loan yes okay unless there's something
else dictated in her will and
wishes it's your
car okay I mean isn't it your car
now um it's it is in both of our names
yes uh I don't think she has a will but
I am um uh the power of attorney for my
mother okay is she still driving
oh no she can't drive anymore so we
we're paying monthly payments on a car
that's just sitting
there I'm driving it I'm using it I take
her two and from you know appointment so
you don't have a personal
car this is the only car I have okay
what does it take to get her name off of
it just to make it
clean oh I don't know how to go about
that and if I can I don't know
well you would have to be able to afford
the loan on your own would you be able
to afford
it um I don't know honestly that's a
good question what's the car worth what
do I um
23,000 and what do you owe on
it
um the payoff is 23 that's still the
amount okay and what you're not sure
what it's actually worth if you sold it
private party yes I did the k Blue Book
and it shows about 17 to 19 okay so I'm
like upside down about 4,000 yeah
somewhere there and what's your
income my income is about uh 6 to 6500
Nets a month okay is this your only car
or do you have another car that you were
driving before you signed up with this
one for with your
mom uh I have another car that has like
3,000 on it and uh my daughter's using
it how old's your daughter paying for it
um she's
29 what would it look like and what's
her financial situation real quick it
can she afford her own
car not at the moment
no here's what I'm getting to I would
love for everybody to have their own
cars like I would love for your 29
almost 30-year-old daughter to have her
own car that she pays for I would love
for you to then have your car back that
you bought and only owe $3,000 on it and
then I would like you to get rid of this
car that you got with your 83-year-old
mother who no longer
drives that's that's an ideal setting in
my mind because right now it's kind of a
little bit of a
spiderweb I thought about that honestly
but I'm kind of like I feel bad um
because she'll be left without a car and
she is working so I don't know but she's
working right does she have kids
no no case okay she's a fully grown
woman who's got a job I don't think you
should feel bad at about that at all I
think you should feel like wow I'm I
have confidence in my daughter that she
can make it in the real world and pay
cash for a car that she can afford with
her job sure you know what I'm saying I
agree do you have any other
debt a lot of other debt yes and I have
been um listening to the show for a
while now and have made so many mistakes
weeks and now I'm back again I'm
following the Ramsey solution way good
and uh I've put my Deb together and I
kind of have numbers if you want to you
know well I'm wondering are you able to
pay off this car in a year or
two no I don't think so if you can't pay
it off in the next year or two I would
sell it and I would scrape up together
the money that you're under water on
that's $4,000 scrape that up sell the
car be done with it and get you some get
a beater car for now until you can
upgrade what's the pay My worry is about
I had a beater car and I got rid of it
because they break down and I can't
afford to fix it so that's what made me
go in there and get the new car out
again how long is sorry I'm changing I'm
going in another Direction how long has
your daughter had the $3,000 car has she
had it for a long long
time uh just about a year now she's uh
making the payments and uh paying the
insurance so and is that in your
name yes yeah yeah I look you got a lot
of Financial Risk on your shoulders
right now if it were me I would get that
car back I really would I'd be like hey
I'm glad that this has helped you out
let's get on a plan for you to get your
own car and let's set a timeline for
this because I'm trying to get my
financial house in order and i' like you
said I've made a lot of mistakes and
honestly one of the mistakes I made was
getting our you know getting your
grandma a car and then sliding my car
over to you and I've got to make this
right daughter how long can you how long
will it take for you get a little bit of
cash together so you can buy a car in
cash and so that I can have my car back
so that I can sell Grandma's
car oh okay so that's the plan that I
would set in motion I'd set that plan in
motion today I'd call her up and say hey
let's get on a a three or four month
plan
here gotcha okay so give her a timeline
like to yeah give her some time I mean
you're not going to just snatch it out
from under her but I think I think it's
good for you to say hey I've made
mistakes and I'm trying to get my life
in order and maybe that will push her to
do the same cuz it sounds like she's got
some things to get in order and then in
the meantime what other debts do you
have I have about a
$10,000 uh credit card debt I have the
car obviously it's 23,000 I have a plot
that I just bought which is like
12,000 and I have um tax debt how much
is the tax
debt um I would say 2700 plus 19900
whatever that total is okay one one's a
tax from Utah and one is here in
California okay and what's your income
that you're bringing
in uh I bring in net uh six from 6,000
to 6 oh that's right you did say that
you did say that okay and what was the
plot for was this like a funeral
plot I'm sorry was this a funeral
plot yes the plot for me yes spot it and
I'm making payments on that too yikes
okay I know the Step Zero is to stop
going into debt and that's the hardest
step truthfully out of this whole plan
is just to stop the bleeding go no more
debt is off the table if we can't pay
for it we got to figure out another way
if that means public transportation and
getting on a bike we're doing it but
right now we've got to have that Line in
the Sand otherwise we're going to
continue down this path and there's
always going to be something else that
comes up there's always going to be
another reason to swipe the card so I
would cut up the cards number one and
stick to using your own money all of
them I already have and I paid off one
small debt I did trying to do I'm a step
number two excellent I just have $1,000
and that's all I have the plot you
bought is that for you or were you
trying to help out your mom again no
it's for me my mom has hers that we just
paid off and you know there so all right
this one is mine okay so let's put this
IRS de at the very top of your list list
this trumps everything in the dead
snowball we've got to attack this one
with intensity and get this monkey off
our back get Uncle Sam out of there then
we can start focusing on the smallest
debt smallest to largest we're going to
increase our income we're going to do
what Jade said with this car and get out
from under this weird situation where we
found ourselves in and that's going to
give you some traction right there you
free up that car payment how much is
that uh my car payment is
379 great oh yeah that's about 400 bucks
you can start throwing at the next
smallest debt and the next smallest Deb
and you'll get there in no time this is
not a huge amount of debt comparatively
to your income yeah it's just confused
it's all over the place okay we just
haven't had traction but I love that
you're on the plan now you're ready to
do this thing yes I am and I have a goal
to be debt free and uh I just don't know
when I'm going to get there I'm just
very overwhelmed right now write it down
and put it on your bathroom mirror to
remind yourself every single day and let
us give you every dollar because if you
can plug these numbers into every dollar
it won't be an unknown anymore you can
use the financial road map feature plug
all your numbers in and you can see
exactly when you'll be debt-free exactly
when you'll have your 3 to six months of
savings and that is going to give you a
lot of peace of mind going forward and
you can sign up for our free every doll
webinar we're doing this Friday I'll be
leading it everydollar.com budgeting
I'll walk you through how to set it up
and hang on the line we'll gift that
premium version to you thank you so much
for the call this is the Ramsey Show